belle tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono fa vj e posso fare il
doppiatore
manco per il cazzo comunque ragazze
partito ecco perché non posso fare il
doppiatore c'è un motivo partitoni
agosto la denise all action che è meglio
nello scorso episodio nello questo
episodio dai per favori su quanti ce ne
devono essere di alien fatemi capire di
qua dico ricordo loci veloce ora si
posso correre per me frega un cazzo che
mi 7 da invece forse me ne frega la
doccia ma il bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye non sarà il vostro bisogni cosa noi
cui sono in corso nel culo ai degli
insetti schifosi casa brucia lì col
fuoco
come pato dove vado non c'è niente di
qua storica stato barman [ __ ] che
bellissimi denti dove devo andare di qua
si è ovvio ma tanto proprio merda di
così non può essere guarda ma ci passa
lui qua dentro
io comunque sono veramente contento di
questa cosa è tanto l'avevo ci avrei
scommesso perché mi avete scritto tutti
nei commenti che sarebbe sei morto ma
quanto godia e morto dai lo bruciato lo
bruciato vivo solivo sì sì sono io non
ci credo dice posso mai credere ragazzi
veramente no no no no no no no non lo
vorrei di morire ma le ragazze l'ho
ucciso non hanno ucciso però mandato via
in una maniera che non so come ho fatto
a san non lo so che ce la facciamo ad
arrivare si brucia oppure la famiglia
certo senza è vero perché ho bruciato
gli dilaghi
quanti cazzo sono quanti quanti sono
l'alieno non è la sola minaccia sulla
stazione non ci sono dei cazzo divenni
adesso lo sai mai no no no no sì questo
non c'è non c'è corrente mi ha visto non
ha visto su un cavo ragazzino ma visto
che botta di culo assurdo non ha visto
ceco però è questo titolo di re si sentì
d'addio prossimi è tornato rega è
tornato indietro
dove devo andare a riattivare la così
tanto sono libero di girare in questi
posti bellissimi coste fatemi andare
dove volete di 41 torna indietro seta
con jobs colti e lì che cosa ci fa in
questo è un posto appartato leva di fare
del bunga bunga
ok capo di qua 6 sexy tanto non ci
arrivi qua sotto e inutile che ma non ho
mai visto per questo ho notato anche se
mi vedo non è che può striscia è tornato
su ai vari mente ragazzi programmare il
gioco è stato più semplice che giocarlo
proprio impossibili sì sì ce l'abbiamo
adesso miglior tipo buttare i miei
condotti non sfonda lì dove mi nascondo
che arriverà di tutto torna reattore
c'entrassi tanto ci sono solo 14 all in
in giro cioè quello sente io che cargo e
non sente un reattore cattivo quello che
sarà eco brava se mi viene incontro ti
brucia perché un casino 1300 non
indietreggia però ci sono i ragni che
devono rompere il cazzo
[Musica]
porca vacca non rido stronzo di me 36
soldato fuoco anch'io ma non importa
perché cesar ma che volteggia stesso
cioè non importa
usciamo veloce velocissimo chiudi che
udc vd chiudi tv di kew di chio di bravo
bravo bravo
io non ce la posso più farmaco si
finisce questo gioco i miei capelli ne
stanno risentendo e distruggere ma dai
praticamente ragazzi devono devo
scassare questi cosi il problema è che
io lo faccio sesso sovraccarico st roma
prima intel nido di prima di aliens
minchia tutti esplodono però il problema
è che lo devo fare io non lo può fare
qualcun altro non ti posi stronzi che
comminano una donna che picchia la mamma
ragazzi sono circondato da 427 android
pam lordo non è morto nessuno cazzo cioè
la fascia bucherellata pro nemo l'ovvio
e certo punto di vita che schifo melo
togliti se mi tocchi ti ammazzo bravo ma
[ __ ]
no proprio no l'accordo ragazzi siccome
non va non va bene se usa le maniere
tranquille vado con le maniere forti
proprio l'ho fatto l'ho fatto che cosa
devo fare adesso ti togli lo ricordiamo
anni per favore
cosa devo fare e muori io seriamente non
ho capito un cazzo di quello che ho
fatto ma va bene bene a posto abbiamo
svuotamento della sacco in queste cose o
fare ancora che si sta partendo con
firma ferrari che sono rumore ma ti
prego ti prego ti prego tease con giusti
regalo la bambola qualcosa natale si è
già aperto grazie a dio ce l'abbiamo
fatta
perfetto ok oh mio dio un attimo dica 15
secondi di calma ce li abbiamo
giusto per capire perché non è possibile
devo tornare su e poi attivare sta roba
se non muore alien mi girano le palle
questo è il finale credo miglia è
possibile per fare ci ho messo mezz'ora
si a posto siamo siamo della star di
questo bellissimo i condotti che finisco
proprio nella stanza che ci serve a
posto vai abbia lo sfruttamento freccia
su freccia giù pur vai vai vai mai mai
mai virus o posto tieniti forte amica
traballa tutto ragazzi ci siamo
a posto è saltato tutto ok è la madonna
fida e casinò proprio
qualcosa specie che ci sarà un black out
però non lo so è un mio pensiero questo
si farà male al mister obiettivo è vero
è salito sopra ma serio è salito sopra
il reattore ma esplode tutto tipo non è
sposato
norton è morto in gol
[ __ ] di mick esplode per favore
almeno adesso cosa devo fare
ragazzi non è morto nessuno sono ancora
tutti lì torna ad arica si vabbè ma è
pieno di alien ancora cosa dove quanto
deve continuare questa cagata può
tornare quindi al come si chiama il
centro medico perfetto nota la prima in
tre ragazzi devo trovare un ambulanza di
quelle spaziali dalle navicelle
piccoline perché c'è una nave che sta
vicino alla nostra bastasse andrò basta
gli androidi supplico basta basta avete
rotto il ca non ti sparo neanche mi fai
schifo i files chi fa i proiettili mi
fai schifo
merda merda no no no no no no no no sono
già fiamme pesca scarico lanciafiamme
scarico non sapevo che era casa stavolta
vado di molotov raga perché non è
possibile che devo morire ogni [ __ ]
volta di qua ci siamo ragazzi ci siamo
allora credo di averlo trovato avrebbe
essere qua è forse sì dov'è cosa clicco
cosa che faccio andrea ecco questo
perfetto
e vabbè allora tenterò infili nel capro
anzi cerca un potenziamento di livello 3
si è ovvio dove lo vado a trovare agosto
non pensavo di trovare 0,3 secondi
prendevo di dover tornare indietro però
va bene così
ok cosa faccio da ceramica peggiori
degli anonymous tanto sento nei condotti
quella stronza che con lo stronzo si sta
muovendo l'ho sempre qua mi fai entrare
per favore grazie è molto gentile io
faccio ragazzi ci posso fare mai sto
partendo sto partendo via via tosca
pandola la nave spaziale non ci credo
tanto so che qualcosa di sis di atella
sul parabrezza
invece no invece no invece è
fottutamente no cosa devo fare adesso la
valle suo comando io posso andare a casa
tipo comando non dai serio adesso che
sono fuori dalla mischia costa navicella
possiamo andare a finire questo gioco
che non ne possono più di infarti e cose
così no ragazzi bisogno gli androidi di
notte questo il problema che è dove sono
arrivato a ok ho trattato sull'altra 9
che non ci dovrebbe essere niente su
questa nave ragazzi siamo sulla nesi
dora che sarebbe l'altra nave bellissimo
ma io volentieri se hai voglia di cosa
cosa dove ma anche qui perché no salve
no no no no per brown no non ci posso
che di vista abbassa quella quella
armate la sparano i [ __ ]
cosa fa
il reattore diffusione distruggerai la
accetterà ogni traccia di quella creato
è l'unico non ti va bene regalami chiama
cello sta facendo un disastro
e ancora vederlo doppio fallo
viva
grande zia fantastico ma playstation fai
la playstation vai così ragazzi devo
capire un attimo cosa come faccio a
disattivare questo già marcella ragazzo
l'ansia che l'ansia io manco mi stesso
esplodendo a meno in casa sta roba a
posto
davvero
cazzo cazzo vabbè è stato bello ascolta
io vado ciao seriamente dai partiti anzi
cosa facciamo adesso
e molto bene bene così
scappa scappa l'avevo detto io l'avrei
fatto molto prima della scritta scappa
va bene se l'abbiamo nel deretano cosa
tanto per cambiare lega non è che merda
dove vado imboccare la navicella di
prima di nuovo novero ragazzino nel culo
perso abbiamo perso
e stato tutto inutile fino adesso potevo
morire subito era uguale gli appoggi
pure alle cose
mio zio scalzo un paese ma regala serio
sono in piedi sentiti vai vai alzati dai
forza donna fai qualcosa per due vadano
di qualcosa saltando in aria benissimo
sembrava il corridoio quando andavo a
scuola a prendere le pagelle uguale
forza dio forza non ce la faremo mai
tanto lo stop arrivato 6 gatto selicato
segato appunto ai re branding sgancio
fai qualcosa non so cosa fallo però ok
carni l'ansia che sta salendo a mille
pazzesco apostolo siamo noi non ti fa
vedere il tragitto priverà tanto per
cambiare
per una mancia di pompei
non bastavano i robot anche gli esseri
umani devono pagare le palle ma è
possibile mai ti voglio fare del mare
giuro pro ti farò del male
dispiace è sei brutto non so come faccio
se ci sono pure sistro anzi mi mancava
ci mancava veramente solo questo ciao
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
concludo qui l'episodio credo che il
prossimo pensano quasi sicuro che sia
l'ultimo perché minchia non ce la posso
più farci altro finale di merda che deve
arrivare ma [ __ ]
il prossimo sarà l'ultimo deciso decido
io ci faccio io qui di ragazzi servizio
è piaciuto ma sa di passato momento mi
piace anche a progetti facebook e cavani
video trattare tiziana sensi dovresti
disgrafici diavolo fosse una bella
ragazza
[Musica]